été condamné une première fois en
septembre 2020 à deux ans de prison avec
sursis 50 mille euros d'amendé trois ans
de privation des droits civiques et
civils dont l'éligibilité tu as fait
appel de cette décision
aujourd'hui
est donc tu étais dans quel état tu es
dans quel monde
j'ai vu ton tweet
tu comprends pas cette décision non je
la comprends pas d'abord merci cyril que
tu m'a sollicitée de que pour venir à
m'exprimer je l'avais pas fait jusqu'à
présent je sais jamais où on n'a jamais
parlé tous les deux puis jamais six ans
que cette affaire a débuté avec une
information judiciaire jamais j'ai voulu
en entendre parler dans les médias parce
que je me disais il faut pas médiatiser
les choses il ya plein de gens qui sont
pris dans des affaires de justice et les
métiers immédiate ispa ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de le faire je mangeais pas
le faire il faut que je me défende comme
citoyen lambda et et que je prouve mon
innocence d'ailleurs mais carrément mais
en tout cas on en a parlé tous les deux
même hors antenne j'aime la nage
achevant les parce que encore une fois
pour moi c'est et c'est moi j'ai
toujours fait confiance à la justice
j'ai jamais critiqué la justice ait
jamais les magistrats de que j'ai
toujours dit ma désapprobation de la
violence du non respect des lois de la
république
je pense que personne peut indiquer que
j'ai pas de discours et public est assez
clair assez ferme de un moment donné où
on avait une suspicion sur ma probité je
me disais il faut laisser faire la
justice faut laisser faire ce temps
d'algérie tristement une enquête et
autres que tu vas pâte exprimé dans la
presse tu vas laisser faire et puis tu
couvres a cogné deux ans cette affaire
elle disparaîtra comme elle est venue
l'heure juste 15 est ce que tu peux
expliquer parce que moi je suis je peux
même pas compris ce qu'on te reprocher
est ce que tu peux expliquer à nos
téléspectateurs pourquoi aujourd'hui il
a été condamné rapidement la génèse en
2012 je suis candidat aux élections
légistatives dans les quartiers nord de
marseille d'accord le 10 juin 2012
premier tour et demi pour ça qu'ils
étaient le plus gros score d'un candidat
cette étiquette en france huit jours
après une lettre anonyme parvient au
parquet le 18 juin une lettre anonyme
disant vous devriez regarder les comptes
de karim zéribi de qu'il s'est servi de
la vie associative de pour sa promotion
politique salette cette lettre elle dit
ça
huit jours après une information
judiciaire pendant un an deux camps
quête sans que je sois au courant invité
à m'exprimer rayé
ou de deux ans il ya à peu près une
dizaine quinzaine de personnes qui ont
été en garde à vue qui sont exprimés
contre témoigné autres donc
j'apprends qui a un doute sur ma probité
je sollicite le procureur de la
république à l'époque ennuyer monsieur
progressive ou les malades mentaux je
suis disponible vous n'avez pas été
entendus jusqu'à présent je n'ai pas été
entendu j'ai été entendu en 2015
dakaroise ans après façon après trois
ans après en 2015
je suis un déplacement à l'étranger pour
des raisons professionnelles je reçois
un coup de fil d'un commissaire de
marseille qui me dit monsieur zeribi en
de vous entendre demain
de que pour une affaire qui nous
concerne fini je suis à l'étranger sur
le banc professionnel je rentre après
demain sur le commissiariat pas de
problème après demain je viens et je me
rends à cette convocation il dira non
non non vous venez demain puis seul
comme si elle se fait trois ans qu'il ya
une enquête de kay on me tourne autour
et on m'a jamais interrogé dans 48
heures je viens et si ces professionnels
c'est important c'est mon boulot il dit
mais je dirais bien on va venir vous
chercher sur le tarmac c'est quoi si une
blague c'est le comédien n'ayez pas peur
je rentre enfin je viens je rentre 48
ans après je me rends alors vous n'êtes
pas les lendemains finalement vous avez
après je suis arrivé le mercredi avec
l'accord de mon avocat qui a appelé la
crainte que le magistrat le magistrat
niveau ainsi peut pas faire autrement et
qui viendra mercredi je suis hanté le
mercredi et là je fais quarante huit
heures de garde à vue je réponds à tous
je suis tranquille je suis serein je
reste quand vous leur dites nous c'est
quoi les questions d'avoir utilisé les
associations pour lesquelles j'ai milité
toujours bénévolement en tant que
président fondateur agir pour la
citoyenneté agir pour leurs premiers ils
vous reprochent d'avoir utilisé l'argent
l'argent pour faire ma promotion un
quatre pages associatif où il ya les
actions de l'association mais il ya
aussi ma tête ah vous avez utilisé ça
pour votre promotion politique parce que
en 2001 je crée des associations en 2007
et en 2012 je me présente aux élections
en fait ils estiment que je savais que
six ans après d'accord une blouse javier
fesser asocial comment vous servir de
ces associations les le tous les
supports qu'avait l'association x comme
à des fins politiques à des fins de
promotion politique demain présenté
derrière je rappelle que je fais
l'émission les grandes gueules depuis
2004 sur rmc d'ailleurs relations c'est
là que c'est là que je vais chez neil
stein de mon père et je leur explique ma
notoriété c'est pas les associations qui
me l'a donnée je n'ai toujours été
bénévole regarder les cohortes jamais de
tous y'a pas une roue de sentiers mais
qui est venu chez moi rien donc non mais
monsieur zeribi le 4 pages donc vous
allez être servis vous l'avez distribués
et d'autres derrière ça a fait votre
promotion je leur dis non c'est les
médias je suis dans les médias et c'est
plus moi qui portais les associations
que les associations qui vont porter ce
que et là je leur apporte des éléments
concrets par exemple dans cette affaire
on me reproche d'avoir perçu du conseil
régional paca nous subventionne de
175000 euros
il va sur l'association oui sur
l'association que la station aurait reçu
une subvention de sa venue avait reçu
non je redis on n'a jamais reçu jamais
jamais on n'a pas on n'a pas reçu de
subvention de 75 ml du conseil régional
paca monsieur zéribi on vous dit que
vous l'avez reçu écoutez c'est ce qu'on
veut faire mon avocat
ils sont tous tout ce qu'on le voit
quand on reçoit 75 évidemment j'ai
apporté un document si on peut le passer
à l'antenne de cas la régie on a écrit
au conseil régional paca est ce que
cette association en toucher la
subvention j'ai bien reçu votre courrier
un objet vous confirme qu'aucune
subvention n'a été versée avec les
insurgés pour la combattre j'adore ça la
juge l'accord j'ai l'impression que j'ai
rien donné
jeudi dans cette affaire l'homme je suis
frustré la ou les cures mandali ce que
j'ai l'impression que j'ai apporté les
éléments on peut porter la suspicion sur
moi sur la base d'une lettre anonyme qui
n'est pas dans le dossier d'ailleurs on
me dit c'est une lettre anonyme elle
n'est pas dans le dossier d'instruction
mais passons
pour des éléments de preuve j'apporte
des comptes on n'est pas en mesure de
dire qu'il ya un euro de centimes qui
est passé des comptes associatif donc à
mes comptes personnels j'apporte là la
démonstration que cette subvention n'a
pas été touché 2 j'apporte tous les
éléments moi je suis serein je me dis
cette affaire c'est un mauvais moment il
ya des gens qui peut-être ont été
dérangés par mon score par mon mot
émergence politique à marseille ça
existe vous avez vous aviez l'impression
de nous dire il ya quelques minutes que
les 21% que vous avez fait lors des
élections dans les quartiers nord de
marseille
juste après avait une corrélation quand
même avec ses sept lettres anonymes
penser que c'est quelqu'un de
l'association car c'est le parvient huit
jours après au parquet je suis obligé de
me poser des questions moi ce qui s'est
passé là trop nul n'est pas dans le neuf
et j'avais su qu'ils cèdent qui avait
fait ça auparavant
oui c'est un cfa la cérémonie mais en
même temps je veux pas me comporter
comme une victime je veux pas dire c'est
un complot machin c'est donc défend
s'agit jamais voulu à tenir vous
reproche d'avoir utilisé des supports de
l'association le local associatif a fait
des réunions politiques alors que je
démontre qu'il ya un bail du local de
campagne qui coûte plus cher en loyer
que le bail du local associatif je le
démontre il ya déjà des ja les
redevances et des photos et à tous j'ai
l'impression que les preuves apportées
ne sont jamais suffisante je réponds à
toutes les questions jeunes à des lunes
aucune et un moment donné je me sens
acculée
comme si les magistrats avaient presque
décidé avant que je m'exprime et avant
que je produise quelques pièces que ce
soit de la décision il ya encore une
fois je ne crierai jamais au complot
politique parce que j'ai toujours
défendu la justice j'ai toujours défendu
les magistrats je n'ai jamais dit mais
non là il ya des gens qui m'en veulent
il ya un complot non je dis simplement
il ya 202 deux solutions pour moi
soit ils n'ont pas le temps de regarder
le dossier qu'on leur fournisse pas
possible parce que la justice est
débordés ont fait que nous le dira
quatre autres dossiers et autres parce
qu'on a fourni à mes avocats des
dossiers de 100 pages avec des photos
avec des éléments utiles preuve vous
étiez confiant xiiie siècle et 10ème
appel si tu es pas confiant face à cette
première sanction au départ alors
justement je voulais le dire aux
téléspectateurs parce que première
sanction en 2020 deux ans prison avec
sursis cinquante mille euros damende
trois ans préfère ici privation des
droits civiques et civils pour
l'éligibilité fait appel donc ça veut
dire que vous êtes sûr de vous pensez
que la peine va être moindre je le vis
comme une injustice je fais appel
exaltant et là on passe de 2 ans à trois
ans de prison avec sursis de 50000 euros
damende à 80000 euros damende de cinq
ans à deux trois ans à cinq ans de
privation des droits civiques et civils
dont éligibilité et en plus cinq ans
d'interdiction de gérer une entreprise
au delà total donc là c'est une peine
très lourde très lourde et là tu te dis
je fais appel
je suis avec mes avocats déterminés à
démontrer mon innocence
2 que j'apporte des éléments
supplémentaires ce plan matériel et en
droit maritime compte de juillet sont
des hommes en matériel pas sur des
on-dit pas sur des rumeurs pas sur des
témoignages point stationnement de gens
que à qui vous plaisait pas et là quand
la sentence est tombée hier le verdict
au meilleur prix un coup de massue quand
je suis c'est pas possible tu fais pas
appel si tu sais que tu as des charges
aussi lourdes à te reprocher et là j'ai
l'impression au verdict puis j'ai
détourné des millions d'euros comme on
reprocherait des choses abominables et
autres très franchement ce qu'on me
reproche c'est un quatre pages c'est un
sondage associatif c'est devant utiliser
des locaux sciatique ça se joue à
quelques dizaines de milliers d'euros si
c'était vrai il ya les 160 et 175 mille
euros qui n'existe pas mais je sais pas
c'est aussi ça a été retenue dans le
dossier sur à sète hérault dans le
journal la provence parle aujourd'hui
d'une subvention du conseil régional
paca donc alors tu veux je l'aï jamais
rien eu et n'a jamais été versée on l'a
vu dans l'ain dans la lettre ne
comprends pas c'est un confrère ils ont
l'écoeurement un moment donné était
dépité tu te sens tu es un coup de
massue que tu penses sur la tête tu dis
c'est pas possible c'est un cauchemar
après moi je suis quelqu'un de déterminé
je quelqu'un qui me dit voilà c'est une
épreuve c'est une épreuve quelques que
tu dois vraiment réagi votre famille
très proche de votre animal way est très
mal toute la famille elle l est a été
décomposé hier je vous dis la vérité ont
pensé que j'en ai trop relax et nation
mais mes avocats aussi on se disait mais
cette journée là où on est allé défendre
à l'appel à une journée on a répondu à
tous on était convoqué à 14h au départ
jusqu'à 18 heures la juge nous dit est
ce que vous êtes d'accord pour venir le
matin 9h pas problème ou plus on va
prendre le temps au mieux on pourra
entendre le dossier 9 heures mes avocats
sont trois heures de plaidoiries il
apporte tous les éléments juridiques
éléments de preuve matérielle tout je
sors honnêtement je suis persuadé je me
dis c'est du bon boulot est-ce que des
pièces contre vous au tribunal aucune
pièce matériel des témoignages des
témoignages des témoignages de quoi les
témoignages quoi ces témoignages karim
zéribi et s'est servi de l'association
tel un véhicule politique un bénévole de
l'association
quelqu'un qui était dans l'entourage de
l'association qui dit hamé
il nous a demandé de venir l'aider sur
le plan politique il faisait des
réunions dans le local associatif
des témoignages qui crée le doute qui
crée la suspicion qui crée un contexte
un peu de l'atmosphère de malaise moi je
dit aux juges
j'entends j'entende moi je vous prétend
le contraire je vous le prouve local
associatif vous met un local de campagne
à côté avec un bail là quand je suis
bien sûr je vous dis qu'on n'a pas été
touché
les les les salariés j'ai pris une
société spécialisée dans l'eau tractage
le boîtage spécialisés qui sont nommés
comptes de campagne mes comptes de
campagne c'est un enfant ou soirée comme
fournissez toutes ses preuves et vous
disent pas me les témoins ils prennent
acte i te disent rien et là tu dis bon
c'est bien il ya des preuves matérielles
il ya les éléments on est en plaidoirie
on le dit on dit que et c'est quand le
verdict tombe que tu te dis mais c'est
pas possible on a l'impression qu'on a
rien donné c'est ça c'est ce sentiment
là qui me prend aujourd'hui kim ambani
si c'était kerbala si on avait prouvé
par a plus b monsieur zéribi vous avez
se relever là pourquoi il ya eu ce
virement de 1000 euros de l'association
bien votre compte pourquoi or moi il n'y
a pas eu jamais jamais jamais pas un
élément financière karim je suis aussi
cet te laisses ça qui m'a terre et je
vais même te dire mieux à un moment
donné la société en difficulté en 2013
mais en 2013 jeudi je vais aider
l'association son effort personnel j'ai
toujours bossé - elle tient toujours été
bénévole jamie salariée d'une
association meilleur c'était quoi
inscriptions sur les listes électorales
dans les quartiers créer un parlement
des quartiers pour que les jeunes
s'expriment les habitants des quartiers
s'exprime on a filé présence du
président l'association j'étais
président sales l'accord d'association
et ensuite j'ai passé la main à des
jeunes qui ont pris derrière on a invité
ségolène royal en 2007 pour un débat à
villeurbanne j'étais candidat
marseillais ont fait le parlement débat
lyon-villeurbanne pas un seul parlement
débat lié à marseille si je veux me
servir de l'association se réunit des
centaines de jeunes à marseille sont mon
terrain électoral pas un parlement des
banlieues à marseille villeurbanne avec
ségolène royal et mots avec nicolas
sarkozy pour montrer que cette sociaux
n'étaient pas partisane sur le plan
politique on a évité les deux candidats
les deux candidats ont leur fournit un
livre plein travail de l'association et
les livres blancs il faut prendre des
imprimeurs non mais vraiment vous a
servi pour votre campagne c'est pas
possible j'ai fait le sondage pour voir
les attentes des habitants des quartiers
47 question il ya une question site est
est ce que vous connaissez en notoriété
fadela amara malek boutih karim zéribi
christiane taubira il ya cinq sinon une
question sur 47 le sondage c'est un
sondage politique monsieur zéribi il
fait pour vous aider dans votre
addiction c'est un sondage national je
me présente à marseille tout ça on amène
des preuves on décortique l'institut de
sondage fine attestation de dix ans ça
peut pas être un sondage politique les
quotas il commence sa quinzaine à qui l
on ne vote pas monsieur zeribi la fin
son âge sociétal qui a servi le livre
parlement des banlieues tout ça on le
prouve en la mène et je me retrouve
acculé de charge il ya des gens qui ont
commis des presque d d d d d accéder il
faut plus grave ils ont pas si penola on
me prend presque ma maison confiscation
j'écris depuis 25 ans sur ma maison
c'est facile à boire 25ème crédit
foncier de france veut dire allez pas
encore fini d'être payés à
l'amplification ça te fait mal là c'est
tombé en intégrité est mise en cause
c'est tombé en absence ali benali médian
de saly saly ton nom on salit ta famille
évidemment que tu peux pas bien le vivre
évidemment que tu le vis mal surtout
quand ils droit dans ses bottes quand tu
veux une grande gueule sur le plateau
télé que tu dis les choses qu'on me tue
les pinces cas l'impression monnaie de
déranger tu te dis qu'est-ce qui a soit
la justice est débordée elle sait pas
traiter un dossier où serpentent des
éléments matériels son beau te la faire
on veut te faire taire tu es obligé de
te poser cette question si vous avez été
condamné à une confiscation en valeur de
son domicile à concurrence de 100 9000
euros ça veut dire quoi ça j'habite dans
les quartiers nord de marseille j'ai une
maison que j'ai fait côtoyer ya 25 ans
25 ça veut dire que ça ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui alors ses 109 mille euros
et il les explique de la manière
suivante parce que l'abus de bien social
c'est quand vous avez une société et
qu'on considère que vous avez dépensé
l'argent de cette société qui est votre
argent l'on parle pas de l'argent
associations de votre argent à des fins
qui était destinée à un autre objet que
la société est là mon fils était gérant
de la société mon fils ryan mon fils
aîné il était un bts négociation
relation commerciale une dit je vais
être gérant de la société papa je suis
en bts et autres donc je veux faire le
siège de la société à la maison vous
prenez toutes les professions
indépendantes
les artisans et beaucoup le siège de la
société de leur société à la maison il
fait le siège ryan de la suite à la
maison qui aménagé un bureau on me dit
les travaux que votre fils a fait pour
aménager bureau de kate une petite
véranda de 30 mètres carrés où il a fait
son bureau il a mis un coin pour déposer
des archives de la société il était
gérant se dit révulsé pour embellir
votre maison sera dit c'est pas possible
si ryan prend la gérance il fait appel à
des artisans etc démontrer que c'est
pour le siège c'est une entrée séparée
de la maison tout est fait pour qu'on
puisse distinguer la maison de ce siège
on me dit ben non monsieur zéribi on
considère que c'est un abus de bien
social avec l'argent de la société que
nous avons gagné papa de fonds publics
on parle pas d'association et là mon
fils il dit mais attendez c'est pas
possible cc c'était moi le gérant s'il
ya quelqu'un qui a fauté sur nous estime
x une fois que c'est moi oui c'est vous
de votre père était complice et man ont
mené sur la tête à l'abus de bien social
alors que ryan après six mois avec
sursis ça veut dire que quelque part tu
te dis ça suffit pas le gérant il dit si
une erreur que vous estimez j'assume
factuellement dès que même si on
conteste le fait que c'était un siège
social c'est pas fait pour l'emmener à
la maison mais non ça suffit pas que le
fil soit condamné à six mois on va
mettre aussi sur le père la confiscation
d'une part de la maison sang neuf mais
look là on vous confisque 109 1909 mis
leur dire quoi sans lui ce 80000 euros
dahmane ça fait 5 80 tu te dis ça tu dis
là détourné des millions le mec si
encore quelques dizaines de milliers
d'euros dont on parle et la vie
associative
encore une fois c'est grave parce que la
vierge s'est tissé des fonds publics
pour moi les fonds publics sont sacrés
j'ai donné quinze ans de ma vie un
bénévole dans les quartiers populaires
où je suis né quinze ans parce que
j'avais le sentiment que ça se déliter
se font perdre est effectivement
l'identité citoyenne républicaine laïque
il ya une forme de ghettoïsation
je voulais les transmet à récurer
aujourd'hui et curé tu vas faire ça
bénévolement je passe quinzaine de
tables sont toujours de repos de qui on
te dit un homme monsieur zeribi le 4
pages que vous avez fait oui à ségolène
royal c'est pour vous mettre en avant
politiquement ségolène royal monsieur la
magistrat était l'invité du parlement
des banlieues c'est l'action de
l'association juste 4 km et qu'ils ont
suivi cette lettre anonyme qui est à la
base
et qui n'est pas dans le dossier de
toute cette enquête sur vous la personne
qui a fait cette lettre anonyme c'est
qu'elle se disait il fait des choses
dans l'association que j'ai envie de
dénoncer ou quoi non je pense moi moi
sentiment c'est que je suis arrivé à
marseille metz aller à marseille moi je
suis né à avignon un même un proche de
signer à marseille et autres bon je vais
pas contredire à chaque fois c'est ce
qu'ils peuvent le passé je suis né
avignon je suis arrivé à marseille en
2006 d'accord 2006 en 2006 je m'engage
en politique
et je fais 21% donc ensuite en 2012 j'ai
eu une ascension quand même assez
fulgurante j'étais président de la régie
des transports de marseille qui la ratp
marseillaise par mon ascension politique
j'étais conseiller municipal j'ai été la
métropole et des gens qui ont une
trentaine de politiques qui n'ont pas ce
parcours je suis arrivé tel un intrus il
arrive il fait des scores dans les
quartiers ça adhérer les gens suivaient
il faut se dire j'ai un ami très bien
placé à marseille je suis pas dire son
nom qu est extrêmement connue qui
m'envoient vivre vive la politique à
marseille tous et qui l'a balancé si
vous avez lancé et qui il a toujours
fait chier voilà ses comptes de campagne
ont été validés par le conseil d'état
bien sûr mais surtout 2012 c'est
quelqu'un voit la dodo place et voilà
qu'ils m'envoient ca 2007 et 2012 compte
validé rien à me reprocher et emprunts à
la banque pour financer ma campagne
c'est pas défensif on prend la banque
clair net précis avec des pinces facture
monsieur ennemis dont vous savez c'est
les salariés pour tracter normes sur le
magistrat regardez dans les comptes de
campagne c'est une société spécialisée à
la part et je vais pas payer une société
si j'ai des bras gratuit vous savez vous
savez qu'il parle cette personne qui
m'en vais c'est me rends pas du tout non
non c'est pas tant honnêtement non et je
vais vous dire cyril de guam de toi moi
et je vais te dire si et
quand cette lettre anonyme arrive et
elle n'est pas dans le dossier et quand
je vois les interrogatoires et autres je
me dis je vais regarder le dossier
lorsque j'aurai accès j'ai accès au
dossier il ya un capitaine de police qui
interrogeait un peu une trentaine de
personnes à un moment donné je regarde
les auditions et mes avocats question
connaissez-vous monsieur untel à la
personne la personne répond une autres
personnes étaient interrogées
connaissent évolution est elle même
réponse
le capitaine en charge poser des
questions et les réponses de personnes
différentes qui étaient interrogés à
trois mois d'intervalle les auditions à
virgule près si les questions et les
réponses là je veux dire mon avocat pain
béni on voit bien que les jeunes c'est
pas eux qu'on parlait il fait des
questions les réponses on va le faire
valoir au procès mais sûr qu'on va le
faire bas leur procès on donne ça au
président du tribunal mais c'est le
président et qui avait une ambiguïté là
à la virgule près si ça tournait autour
encore à la virgule près hautmont près
les personnes à quatre mois d'intervalle
qui se connaissent pas dit la même chose
les mêmes réponses aux mêmes questions
il fait les réponses et les questions de
capitaine c'est une audition de ça c'est
normal ça a été présent quand je réponds
pas on vous répond pas on vous regarde
en pract vous regarde quand vous amenez
une preuve une photo que vous avez un
local de campagne et vous dit ça c'était
le local associatif regardez local de
campagne et une effigie les plus grands
et coûte plus cher tenez le bail on
regarde on tracte et là tu te dis dans
la rédaction hamon a donné des éléments
d'accusation tout ça va être pris en
compte karim sur nt tranquille on sait
que quand tu m appelles tu dis bon on
m'appelle c'est parce qu'on a
suffisamment d'éléments sinon il va
parce que vous pensez que votre
personnage médiatique a joué contre où
je pense que quand on vous voit beaucoup
comme vous en tant que vous parlez un
peu fort que vous dit les choses
franchement s'applique pas est ce que
vous appelez pas ça a été évoqué
tout ce que vous avez fait en télévision
que ce soit dans les grandes gueules ou
chez nous nos balances ton post ou pas
du tout la première instance à la prison
du tribunal commence en me disant moi je
vous préviens je vous connais pas je
regarde pas la télé c'est pas le sujet
moi je veux pas qu'on me dise si on me
regarde ça me regarde pas moi je veux
pas moi je veux pas qu'on juge karim
zéribi je compte du jeune citoyen est-ce
qu'il a fauté est-ce qu'il n'a pas fauté
honnêtement je suis end si je parlais à
un langage populaire juré sur la tête de
mes enfants si j'avais quelque chose à
me reprocher
je paye et c'est terminé on n'en parle
plus le ferions appelles tu fais rien tu
dis est là vous cette affaire derrière
tu dis c'est terminé mais quand y'a rien
à te reprocher tu n'acceptes pas la
décision tu dirais tellement injuste et
incompréhensible
j'ai donné tellement d'éléments jeu mais
tellement d'explication suffire mais ses
avocats il était 3h d'appels 3 3 heures
et demie de plaidoirie il amène éléments
juridiques domaine les éléments de
preuve matérielle et en face y'a pas
d'éléments matériels tu dis quand même
ils ont pas jugé les magistrats sûr je
dirais leur leurs sentiments leurs
intentions ils vont juger sur des
éléments il ya des éléments tangibles
qui dit que karim zéribi à profiter de
la vie associative oui ou non c'est un à
part qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
cette grande gueule on le condamne au
parent s'il y en a on le condamne on ne
traite pas comme karim zéribi
chroniqueur intervenant dans la vidéo on
le traite comme un citoyen s'il a fauté
il doit payer s'il a pas faute et il n'a
pas payé même si sa gueule ne nous
revient pas quand même si par le fort
quand même c'est quoi la suite pour vous
maintenant que j'ai fait un pourvoi en
cassation d'accord donc pourvu en
cassation ça y est c'est fait
c'est croyez penser que la décision que
je vais aller où cyril quand tu y es
innocent tu vas au bout j'épuise les
tout toutes les voix parce que ce sera
la dernière c'est la 4 la dernière à
cassation et tu te dis à mon année il ya
des magistrats qui vont regarder ce
dossier et qui vont faire du droit et
seulement du droit sans regarder qui
jugeait pas ce qu'on s'en fout encore
une fois dès qu'il jugeait sa taille
soit nicolas sarkozy un citoyen lambda
ou karim diaby s'est pas de charge
combien de temps sa carrière
malheureusement je pense que ça va
prendre encore entre 9 et non neuf mois
un nom d'accords de paix est là là là
j'suis présumé innocent mais jeter
l'envié encore d'accord parce que là ça
suspendre toutes les charges d'accord
toutes les accusations claes est
suspensif et thurau par est suspensif et
tu est présumé innocent d'accord le
problème c'est qu'on ne regarde pas
comme un présumé un ensemble clair ce
tapage qui est présumé coupable bien sûr
il ya le doute alors ce qui te soutiens
médiatiques bien sûr te disent on est
avec toi tu es un homme authentique
tiens donc à des convictions on peut pas
croire ceux dont on t'accuse mais se
quitter mais pas trop qui était un peu
les charognards qui te contesté tout à
l'ail et là il se régale les yeux sur
les réseaux sociaux qui avait beaucoup
de gens qui vers agit maintenant des
gens qu'ils vous défendez qui exactement
que des agents marmi qui exactement en
même temps c'est là que tu vois les gens
sur qui tu peux compter dans ces moments
là bien sûr est ce que tente quand
effectivement tu tu payes visite et
puiser toutes les voies mais il ya des
gens qui lisent en cassation ça va
passer et karim si tu ne c'est une cour
de magistrats la cassation qui fait que
du droit ils font que du droit nokla
nonobstant la personne qui serait pas
moi mes avocats n'y seront pas c'est un
avocat spécialisé en cassation qui va
apporter les éléments
disant voilà karim zéribi est accusé
pour abus de confiance l'abus de
confiance ne tient pas là but social sur
cet aspect là ne tiennent pas la
communication de la maison juridiquement
ne tiennent pas c'est ce que disent mes
avocats tous ces éléments là en droit on
va déposer sur la table d'accord et
après mais la cour de cassation elle va
statuer moi je crois qu elle sature à un
monde pour casser certaines accusations
qui ont été portées est ce qu elle
cassera tout j'ai encore confiance je
veux toujours la voir karim toujours
l'avoir bien sinon si tu baisse la tête
tu parles des pressions et tu te dis
finalement d'assaut cauchemar tu t'en
sortir à jamais je suis quelqu'un de
plutôt optimiste je suis croyant vous
allez vous et je me dis je me battrai
jusqu'au bout karim vous allez rester
avec tous dans btp quand bien sûr si
rien de sûr avec vous je vais au bout du
monde